social d'abord la journée de
protestation des médecins contre la
nouvelle convention qui doit l'ailier
pour cinq ans à la sécurité sociale
son écho a été très inférieure aux
derniers mouvements dits ministre la
santé très rares sont les départements a
dépassé les 50% de grévistes du côté de
la confédération des syndicats médicaux
on avance en revanche une moyenne de 60
% avec des pointes et des bas je
rappelle que de leur côté la cgt la cfdt
et la haine protester parallèlement non
un double secteur médecine de riches
médecine de pauvres non à la nouvelle
convention mise au point par la caisse
d'assurance maladie est la fmf
organisations de médecins minoritaire
c'est lé slogan du 23 mai journée
nationale de protestation pendant
laquelle les assurés sociaux ont reçu
l'appui du syndicat majoritaire chez les
médecins
la csn fermeture des cabinets pour les
médecins qui assurait toutefois les
urgences débrayages et manifestations
pour la cgt la cfdt et la fédération de
l'éducation nationale
à noter que force ouvrière favorable à
la prévention
la cftc qui est content et la cgc qui
s'abstient n'était pas au rassemblement
de montparnasse
cela dit si tous les participants
refusent le projet de convention tous
les intérêts ne sont pas concomitants
comme l'a expressément fumée
la cfdt dit autrement dit médecins et
syndicats ne sont pas main dans la main
même si un généraliste est venu apporter
le soutien de la csmf aux 10000 assurés
sociaux qui manifestaient continuer
l'action que nous avons entreprise